everybody's got their favorite part of
the cycle
there are people who love the wash they
love the rinse or the spin or the drain
i'm a spin guy i love the spin
there it goes
my name is john charles and i'm a washer
collector uh enthusiast
laundry day
the club got started around 1987 i think
and now we have like 3 000 members from
all over the world
but we get together for wash-ins you do
laundry till like four in the morning
you do your margaritas and your laundry
together the laundry to laundry laundry
we watch the cycles you'll see a lot of
us just stand there and watch the whole
cycle go through oh my god everywhere
all three thousand of us come in with a
story like i thought it was the only one
i thought it was the only person in the
world that did this
in the collection i've got 59 machines
and i've got 22 hooked up and running
down here in the basement
i have a good representation of
everything that was made
from 1938 to today
and i take them all apart and i restore
them because i want to know everything
works inside the machine and then the
laundry is for me it's sort of like the
frosting on the cake
these machines represent a lot of ways
of doing things in each decade that
change that we no longer do
and i think it's something that should
be preserved for other people
if we can get them interested
i just can't go to a cocktail party say
how's your washer doing they look at me
like i was crazy but i can get together
with these guys let my hair down
it's just so much fun to be able to have
a conversation about it because i know
laundry's a chore for everybody else but
for us it's it's play